so the back decade really started in the
late sixties through 1980 who's a
marvelous time for cell biology
I mean if this work came out of that
time was the revolution for
understanding how synaptic transmission
works there was a of you said and era of
great cell biology so why do you think
that happened and wanted it in
well I don't we could do that secondary
or maybe it is scary as shart Africa it
has it that the focuses on the molecular
biology for swept away are there was a
very time in the controller abortion and
there will be you get these actions tell
Jacqueline what exactly are student and
and she got up and she said well she
said I want everybody know that the
electron close to dying field so one
that we can plot for dying children from
the door half a diary electromagnetic
field to help
no just shut this thing also we're going
to occur but now we have died hill and
you should be forward left to trust the
founders founder of Honor iconic is
becoming sweet esto there was a period
of time people thought they're going to
understand everything by understanding
jeans and under still watching jeans but
you don't understand everything
everything changed
I now finally the technical side
electron microscopes is being addressed
again and new kind electron microscope
sure are appearing in its challenges on
people like John me people were actually
the parish stuff reaction like social
take advantage of these new kinds of
optical things microscopes and use and
that's going to happen in time it's only
understand the whole is only only
understanding of cells not the level of
membranes learning Robert of individual
na todi molecule trial
back up to what time was talking about
the death of electron microscopy that
period one image seems unavoidable there
are a couple of other factors but I'd
like to bring one is that that was a
period of them light microscopy took off
character started fishing and light
microscopy was providing two incredibly
fundamental things that he did not
provide number one the dynamics of self
that actually movements of all of these
things
mind you like my cross to be 1000 the
resolution jump that far away but it was
a whole project display for you and
looking self our second the p.m. and the
light microscopy was allowing you to
begin to identify which floating doing
because new technologies fluorescence
fluorescent protein for coming it could
be examined by light microscopy so it
was nothing electronic us to be dining
with eclipse it was eclipsed by light
microscopy on the huge potential you
want your life and forget it i saw a
little help and then lost my shelter oh
but I'm really is a the critical thing
that we've always been up against and
we're still do it again and the matter
how fancy the electron microscope sketch
or help protect our means viewing it
will never get around the fact that the
electron microscope gives you a static
image still a snapshot of something one
instant in time for each picture that
you take each preparation that you make
one student I'm and you have to pack
extrapolate to what was happening in
life you have to say well i tried to
perfectly 51 seconds seven seconds 20
milliseconds field I can see her to this
and that the map but that's an
interpretation in itself are open to
questions if you've got competitors and
you filled out it's only that
extrapolation of them it's an
interpretation and
that many people shine off only to the
divine of which were not trying to
recover always will be trying to recover
when you are young student in the course
and you came in the end you have a
choice of spending a week doing doing
the particulars preparation to get some
great actually like a sloppy at one
picture or you could put take some jeans
and great some cotton beautiful colors
that was locked down inside yourself
it sits there all options and looking at
which we do hey I sit here and look at
this
that's one picture yeah but what is the
future of electron microscopy then why
what would recommend it to a student
when you have two questions there of
future and what recommend to students
that might be that there's little to
recommend to students
that's what we're really figure out how
many people are going into this field
it's heartbreaking to see how few people
are being trained even these lives that
are totally cutting edge and up the
whole culture to arc on microscopy in
iron danger so still you haven't asked
and answered why they should be trained
what are they going to see you can't be
in a light electron hall arena when you
mean you're very well in there
you mean your idea behold got all
excited about hi Lucia like props to be
super resolution to revolution after
about fifteen hundred percent
improvement maybe they're able to change
something it's a shorter than anything
something and shifting in but we we see
some all the time is one out here two
nanometers with it the the gap between
revolution and I like the slope
electrolytes still eat so I I don't I
I'm eyeball able to my network and I'll
understand about any legal proteins
together to make protein lowers not even
examine our light microscopy but
by violation fluorescent dyes and watch
what happens you can make some
inferences which you don't really know
until you actually they get the images
and we construct the the proteins this
is just looking to talk of his lectures
to this year's students in biology
laboratory and i'm impressed again five
lakers vs I mean keep everything and it
is apparent in every word he says the
students cabling and I totally grooving
that it's a PM resolution a level of
electron microscope that we're going to
understand cell function organelle
function everything about yourself
because you get that level that you can
actually see molecules and holding the
game is seeing molecules interacting
with each other to understand this
machine called life we have to see the
individual molecules interacting with
each other like Mike Ross could be gives
you these wonderful clues that the other
dancing together we're going over here
and there but to see how that machine
works you have to help the revolution of
this instrument and simple fact amazing
that we have the instrument of great
that we've had it for 50 years 60 years
but if it's got an itch in cell biology
and medical science that is
irreplaceable
nope